es la esperanza de cualquiera que tenga
la mala suerte de contraer kobe 19
desarrollar la inmunidad a cualquier
otra infección pero ahora hay más
evidencia de que contagiarse no es
sinónimo de inmunización según la
revista médica the lancet un joven de 25
años de nevada resultó positivo por
segunda vez después de presentar
síntomas dio positivo inicialmente el 18
de abril posteriormente yo negativo el
26 de mayo sin embargo sólo unos días
después el desarrolló síntomas más
intensos que incluyeron dolor de cabeza
fiebre y náuseas y dio positivo de nuevo
el 5 de junio no es la primera
reinfección documentada de los 37
millones de casos registrados en todo el
mundo 5 reinfecciones han sido
descubiertas en bélgica países bajos
hong kong y ecuador- sainz
hemos tenido cinco casos en todo el
mundo lo que obviamente es una pequeña
cantidad por supuesto es preocupante que
la reinfección sea posible pero debería
preocuparse más por infectarse en primer
lugar en lugar de volver a infectarse
que viaje de ficción la secuencia
genética del virus que infectó al hombre
nevada mostró que fue infectado dos
veces por dos cepas diferentes de sars
cop dos científicos dicen que aunque se
necesita más investigación los casos
confirmados de reinfección sólo han
ocurrido en pacientes que presentaban
síntomas lo que significa que las tasas
de infecciones podrían ser más altas
pero pasar desapercibidas entre aquellos
que son asintomáticos las
recomendaciones son tomar precauciones y
seguir los protocolos sanitarios